this week on conflict zone we you kicked
any feet Nigel Farage margarita vestroia
Norbit arrested the deputy prime
minister Matteo Swarovski Praveen
Neurath again non producer Rob
Wainwright hunt and Lucas against found
who no goldish did not chuckle ow
[Music]
I have over the years worked for French
companies I've had businesses in Italy
I've married a German I am NOT
anti-european in any way at all but I
think that what now masquerades as
Europe is a mistake and needs changing
so do I think there are people out there
in Europe that listen to what I have to
say yes I do but this is what this was
your post referendum pitch yeah to the
European Parliament yes last year I know
that virtually none of you have ever
done a proper job in your life quite
wrong worked in business quite raw
indeed ever created a job quite right
and you think quite often dear father
today but let me tell you from the other
bridge for Britain's eleven they feel as
there is an a hang on yes actually I do
so here's the point the United Kingdom
has just voted to leave the European
Union there's a debate when you said
this there's a debate here four days
later so I get up to speak and 400 of
them start booing and jeering and I
thought they still do and I think then I
don't do you know worse as they still go
if they want to do that so I thought let
them have a piece of it what I am saying
here is this it would be a bad thing for
the peoples of Europe if the political
class of Europe willfully go for a bad
deal with Britain because they want to
punish us they want to discourage other
people leaving the club and I do not
think that across much of Europe but the
political elites are held in any high
degree of regard so you can certainly
accuse me of attacking the European
elites but my goodness me they've given
me some - you are taking the elite but
you are a party built and tired by
Elysee mr. Grillo is as you mentioned a
famous comedian casalecchio the
co-founder of your party was a rich
businessman you yourself are a lawyer
and a member of Brussels elite this is
just hip raucous I'm a member of the
Philadelphia
you iron power your income is five times
more than the average income of others
but you are saying that you are not the
elite it's hypocrisy isn't it absolutely
absolutely
it's not hypocracy a you know Bethany
law is a person was worked all his life
and either side at one point to dedicate
itself to the public like game is we are
nearly a getting a team really we are
absolutely not really no it's not up to
us as a leads as politicians a showman
is to decide it's up to people to decide
but we have to say clearly what this
means to vote for populist simple for
extremists I mean I can show it on the
on the on the European Parliament
because people voted for marine lepen
people voted for visitors people voted
for for Australia in Austria they have
no influence and any kind of decision
making process on European level because
populism extremists have no idea what
they are in favor they are you know
working about they are get all but from
Hungary are you talking about the Prime
Minister Poland extremist nationalist
racist or not Viktor Orban got from in
the last mandate from Barroso and from
Viviane Reding a lot of remarks on his
legislation on media on the question of
easing the constitutional law inside of
Hungary and all but delivered on all
these Rima and Poland from Poland not
Kachinsky not for so you can see where
different the right-wing parties are not
anymore theory they are governing in
countries in the European Union on the
other hand we have 80% of support in
Poland for the European Union but you
accept the right of the European Union
to say what it feels is gone on and
they've been very good at this they are
awaiting all of them are pretty
consistent in their belief that the rule
of law order and democracies on this
reservation is understood the situation
they got it over yes that they make they
completely misunderstood what is just
healing yes if you take in consideration
France 2017
core national in the pan the third of
the voters once - yes and I think even
not anymore
10%
your party what changed in France well I
said just as I said before I think we've
we've seen a rise in population in
simplistic ideas in nationalism in
France just like we've seen it in other
European countries so I think this is
rooted in the United States we still
have some selection so this is I think a
reflection that all of the Democratic
parties must have the Socialist Party
have been condemned the conserver he the
so-called Republicans also have been
condemned many many times we have never
been we suppose you've answered yes they
all not yes you're perfect in every way
yes absolutely yes yes what I really do
believe in is that we don't know if we
don't offer a choice and that's in the
political center and that people have a
real choice when they go to vote then
they search for the extreme and that is
what we have usually not any major to me
a second that is what we have seen with
Trump and some Trump and Sanders for
example that is what we see with
populist movement all over Europe that
if there is no controversial debate
about the future of the country of the
future of society within the political
center then people search for the
extreme wing anyway we're all changing
because the political agenda has moved
on there's no going back to a time
before you have much more sort of
national voices in the European
political debate so there is a lot of
work to do and it will change not only
those who vote for populist or
nationalist party today it will also
change those of us who really strongly
believe in European cooperation Canadian
has been suspended by six countries so
far former president of France Nicolas
Sarkozy said China is dead he's already
pronounced it dead you can't keep this
as one of Europe's sacred cows in the
ear of terrorism Kenya well again that
that's not to go that's that's that's
something the politicians on because you
have an opinion on it I have an opinion
which I'd love to hear it well first of
all I respect the fact the most recent
European survey show the 81 percent of
European citizens still want freedom of
movement
in Europe and that reflects the fact for
over 30 years this has been a very very
significant benefit for millions of
citizens everyday even with the euro
with the euro we've made some grave
mistakes some grave mistakes
for example letting Greece be part of
the Euro burea now sometimes serves a
little oil Ignis was a mistake as a
straightjacket
I don't agree for certainly a mistake I
think some other countries might also
have better joint later on not jointed
or you prefer that Greece is leaving the
eurozone no I mean we've done our utmost
to prevent that from happening because
Greece leaving the eurozone would have
meant that the Euro would have would
have fallen and that would have taken us
all down our banks our pensions our
welfare etc Germany talks about
financial stability in Europe but it's
causing instability you have an 8%
surplus in the current account balance
much more than it is allowed in the
European stability pact and yet for
example you accuse the Greek government
of violating the possibility back and
you're doing the same this is hypocrisy
no you're doing the same are you
relating the stability no we are not
getting % is more than allowed and what
shall we do
what's your proposal I mean what are we
sorry for this to export a lahar percent
are two percent more than the
negotiations without worth six percent
but everyone accepts actually that there
is no real measure that we watch other
again what shall we do we have
increasing waitress we have increasing
salaries we have increasing pensions we
have increasing increasing capital
public public spending we have actually
much more investment money that we can
build somehow as you couldn't have it
now we can your finance minister is
saying he doesn't want to invest he
wants to have no ether it won't win
valve no sorry there's money flowing
back into our budget because the project
we want to finance are not ready to be
built right now public infrastructure in
Germany that it is not done it's not a
problem of money it's a problem
of planning process and then there but I
just say is what what actually shall the
German government do we do invest more
than ever we have included get me just a
second one we have increasing demand we
are very good in exporting that's true
but actually as I said it's helping our
neighbor countries as well because of
the production chain what it is about
actually is to less competitiveness yes
in some other countries we have to
really rethink what was implement was
was not implemented usually you're
talking about a we think you're
demanding basic changes to the EU itself
your structure decision-making process
your leader with the Kachinsky that you
wanted to see a new EU treaty you
imagine or do you think that means these
are a lot of these are a lot of demands
but the fact is you're among the loudest
critics you and the Hungarians no no
your your model for change is that of
the self-declared
a liberal democracy Hungary isn't it
because last several last September your
party leader mr. krichinsky said we are
learning from Viktor Orban the Prime
Minister we are learning from his
example what Hungary has done they have
done lots of good things to bring the
new balance because it was completely
tilted towards selling all the assets to
foreign companies and and the ownership
in Hungarian economy after 25 years of
transformation was in nineteen ninety
percent in hands of foreigners so Viktor
Orban is trying to bring some more
balance into this Toland
does not respect the rule of law and
public is also not respecting the EU and
the Commission nobody is really
respecting the decisions of me you even
not a country which is a member of V U
but I think it is jumping to conclusions
to say that because we have very serious
issues with : no one respects III
doesn't respect Poland doesn't respect
but that is - and the others are really
respecting we are risk of the other
countries respecting for example with
the euro questions
all the necessary is not to spend more
money than it is allowed every country
soon or less is breaking rules in
Germany even France I completely
disagree this is not the Europe I see I
say Europe was still struggling to deal
with maybe the most the deepest crisis
in in modern history of our community
and yet with all that we have overcome
you see people finding ways you have
growth in every country you have jobs
being created unemployment going down
say quietly a beat it is very good
portugal the unemployment of the young
generation is over 20% 30% this is a
success story of Europe no but it is in
the right direction because it was much
much deeper and these countries has been
doing a lot of things to reform their
economies to enable their banks to move
on to support the rest of the economy
these are reforms that has been very
deep one of the goals of your party is
the destruction of the European Union as
it is today why we never stated it we
are against the Europe or we are against
the European Union we are completely
against the priority European Union
yesterday and the way European Union has
worked until today we don't want a
Europe Poots
first the interests of the banking
system the interests of the
transnational corporation or the
interests of the financial system you
saw the big euro skeptic way there is
always having the canova helper defeated
in Austria yet still defeated in an
island if you have d-down if we sat here
five years ago as I said to you that a
presidential candidate from the Austrian
freedom party we come within a whisker
of winning the Austrian presidency
you'd have laughed at me euro scepticism
is on the march everywhere when jong-il
have been got to the second round of the
election in 2002 it was a shock to
everyone today it's not a shock that
deformation is so high this is what has
changed in the country this is very
different there in very different
situation and we can
see this raised of xenophobia and racism
and populism and nationalism in other
countries our lives but a lot of these
young people we are speaking about are
French Muslims did you fail in the
integration I think yes I will say that
I will concede that this is this is this
is an area where the question of how we
treat Islam in the country as been an
issue and because and this is this is
also this has compounded a problem in a
subcommittee including the the economic
problems in the suburbs because we sent
because also we've had of the far-right
and and the right wing party but you
have enjoyed a very close relationship
with far-right groups in America haven't
you over the years we will form a Ku
Klux Klan leader in all day today yes
and he David Duke who was a member of
course if somebody was 18 you know there
are a lot of political leaders who have
been close to the Communist Party who
was responsible for the most awful
totalitarian is no he hadn't renounced
his idea that is still talking about
survival depends on the defeating you is
how he'll say that no madam I do not
ender of the IDS of David Duke I meet
everybody who wants to tell me you're a
great friend okay you're a great friend
of mine I am ready to lead to discuss
and sometimes sometimes I do not agree
let me let me tell you something here
fielder's is running along
anti-immigrant anti-islamic platform
that we see in other countries as well
this is a popular sentiment that goes
very much to the heart of the anxieties
of many people and many of those people
that I meet on a day-to-day basis well
campaigning at this very moment they
feel that we haven't been listening to
them and I think to to largest and they
are right but here builders and this is
not very known or not very noticed has
lost the last four elections in a row
this is definitely not the
and of the discussion about what we want
to do with Europe and who is going to
lead it and in what direction on the
contrary that discussion continues it
will continue in in France it will
continue in Germany it continues in
Denmark it doesn't go away with one
election because some of the questions
that people are asking are completely
legitimate where are we going how are we
as citizen going to make the most out of
of the state of the world instead of
goods being sort of reserved for for
fewer and fewer people it sure that we
have been lacking over the over the
decades in France in general I'm not
saying left or right I think the
government went after the other
government one after the other we've
been with we've been lacking in our
attention to the integration issues with
the second third generation of
immigration most political post
colonization because I think contrary to
other ways of immigration in the past in
France from coming from Europe we've
underestimated the issue of racism Trump
says Marcos refugee policy is a mistake
and this is a very clear state statement
actually it's a completely independent
what he's thinking about Aleppo is
speaking about Chancellor Merkel quote I
think she miracle made one very
catastrophic mistake catastrophic
mistake taking all these illegals a
catastrophic mistake by Angela Merkel
yes as I mentioned this was the one
answer
the other answer referred to Aleppo and
the carnage and the bloodshed there and
my comment on these two answers is that
they seem to be contradictory because
those who fled the carnage the turmoil
the war in Aleppo interior were those we
gave refuge here the cogniser in
solution and shelter in internment like
the solution that Angela Merkel chose I
mean this is very clear
I don't dependent of his point of view
he is criticizing Angela Merkel
very very clearly absolutely on the one
card in the one answer he is criticizing
angular market in the other answer he he
appreciates we may want to leave on this
argumentation I only want to highlight
that I see in the two answers a certain
contradiction this is the only thing I
want to say so you can take it as a
criticism of the one answer because in
the other answer he says these people
have fled this catastrophe and there is
only one solution
if a refugee a human being a child an
old man and old woman if people are
fleeing these a catastrophe there is
only one solution to that
so give shelter and protection to those
who try to create a catastrophe let's so
far we haven't debated enough from my
point of view what do we expect actually
from this immigrants but do we offer
them on the one hand and on the other
hand what do we expect is it just
obeying the laws or do we expect them to
become part of society not living living
with us not next to us and that is the
debate that actually should have taken
place a decade ago when the first
immigrants came in the 60s and 70s but
everyone feels right now this issue
triggered through the migrants the
situation in the past three years the
security issue the question also how are
we defending the borders here again are
we speaking about European army the
European army is for me a long term
approach why not a short term anemy go
have your ethical criteria level go
rather than other borders and if you ask
about border control board control is
not army it's about water security there
are other forces we have to investor and
there Europe did a great step after the
cows of last year in the in the in the
European Union we invested in the
Frontex and today in Bulgaria on the
border region checked to Turkey we have
European forces mr. Kumar's the
possibility to take over the command in
force and they are doing the chops a new
European getting step and step I mean as
mr. Trump said that his involvement in
the NATO is not any more the first
priority is Europe and Europe and
ability to create that Elam everybody
has to contribute and I
this is one of the few points where
Donald Trump is right because when you
see the investments of America in our
NATO security system and then you see
the investments of our taxpayers in the
European Union then it's a fair point
that the American say they are only
repaying for the security there is a
fair point and that's why we have to
invest in my advantages but no just
money money not first of all money is
because we are spending a lot of money
in the European Union in defense the
question is the efficiency how good we
are investing and I would appeal if we
do this more together we would use the
taxpayers money in a more efficient
fivefold you increase the amount of
intelligence the number of tax that I've
seen thwarted across Europe represent a
large degree of success not everyone not
everywhere every attack sadly has been
prevented that doesn't mean that
security cooperation New York is not
working at all of course not this is a
very significant problem as most
authorities see as we've seen sadly now
in Turkey as well as this terrible
attack in Istanbul on New Year's Eve
where it's taken at least a week for the
security authorities in Turkey who are
very resourceful very capable still to
identify him it's the nature I'm afraid
of this very diffuse difficult as a
terrorist threat for us to count I
understand but these are key
intelligence failures were they never
mind what else is going on these should
have been stopped I think indeed even a
killer in this case it had been or
should have been done to exchange the
intelligence to use the instruments of
security cooperation that we have
established in Europe more should have
been done to use those systems in those
cases so the public could be forgiven
for saying that a lousy job was done on
these in these two cases whether the
public should have confidence that most
terrorist attacks are stopped in Europe
probably have confidence when we look at
the number of terrorist attacks that
have taken place in Europe over the last
12 months
which having been stopped well of course
every terrorist attack is a tragedy is a
human tragedy in Europe but they should
recognize that we cannot reduce the
threat to zero I think most most
possible public would understand that in
in the face of what they're obviously
seeing around the world and the way in
which we are dealing with thousands of
radicalized people and a very determined
and well resourced terrorist group
nicest that our intent on carrying the
fight into our back door now as we've
seen from Paris from Brussels and now in
Berlin as well I'm pretty good at
exploiting Europe's weaknesses well they
do their best but but they're done badly
have they well the Emir scored some some
key to accept what they would regard as
key success they've carried out some
spectacular attacks in Europe yes they
haven't calculate successful it
absolutely if you look at Paris it was a
game-changer for our community and
represented a significant challenge lay
down to us to improve our game no doubt
about that first person to admit that
what brings a security to the country is
is the quality of your police the
quality of your services special
services and so on and and given all the
recent polls the level of security in
the society increased people feel more
secure and in Germany in France in Italy
people feel less secure why is this so
if one cannot challenge what is in what
we have especially when it comes to
Europe this project that we if we want
to survive if you want the projects of a
variety we want to survive within the
project this whole project has been
over-promised and under-delivered
look I think what were actually
witnessing is the European projects
dying before our eyes it doesn't work
there's very little residual love for it
yeah I accept there are very powerful
institutions that still back and support
the status quo but yeah I honestly the
life of this project is now time limited
that's a that's a big claim but then I
don't know but then that's your
speciality is big claims things and
getting it right and getting and getting
noticed though I'm getting it right what
I see that we have achieved here gives
us I think the confidence that we can
solve also crisis as deep as this
because the thing is that we have other
crises and they are many and listen then
we haven't chosen ourselves what we can
choose is to take the responsibility to
do something about it and that
responsibility in the strength to do
that comes from amazing thing this is
the longest period of peace in I well
almost well
history because Europe has never been
this peaceful before it was doable but
things are changing are you aware that
things are changing but what is not
changing is the fact that there are
humans citizens who want something else
and it is still for all the crises that
you're piling up you are still one of
the best places to live on earth in
history especially if you're a woman and
that willingness to do something about
it that should not be habit by piling up
crisis that should be an invitation to
engage and do something about it and you
find politicians in every country you
find citizens in every country who want
to do something else then just lean back
and say oh my god everything is falling
apart I will do nothing but protect
myself and on your heart are you even
going to exist with five years times
I've said yes time absolutely as it is
now as it is now even stronger
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]